je m'appelle monsieur greu ma chaîne
parle de votre vie numérique
non ça c'était avant je vais vous
raconter mon histoire différemment ça
c'est moi enfin moi il ya quelques temps
à cette époque là j'avais moins de
cheveux blancs et ils surtout là dessus
et j'avais 3 ans elle les années sont
passées pour arriver là enfin tout cela
j'ai toujours été passionné de nouvelles
technologies à jim première amstrad à 11
ans ma gameboy
magali est la super nintendo et en 2008
une en premier iphone j'aime bien aussi
le champagne mais ça ça n'a strictement
rien à voir
j'y fais de la radio des dents la libre
antenne spéciale beaujolpif qu'on se le
dise j'ai monté plusieurs entreprises et
qui robbie bach liner ingénieur du son
mais au fond de moi j'ai toujours été ce
petit garçon passionné de tech 5 ans et
un jour j'ai décidé de le partager avec
vous je vais faire des vidéos tous les
jours depuis j'ai pris beaucoup d'avions
m
visiter beaucoup de villes genève
londres toronto san francisco new york
amsterdam et lisbonne berlin est où là
barcelone cincinnati mais j'ai également
fait plein de nouvelles rencontres
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok mais surtout je dois lui dire mon
rêve d'enfance en plongeant au coeur des
nouvelles technologies
[Musique]
chaud
sa jeune équipe
mais
non
un seul
ouais
suite
sow